Нова Рада ще не сформована,
а у депутатів вже є важливі домашні завдання.
Позбавити депутатів імунітету українські політики
обіцяють не один рік, проте обранці
й досі можуть захищатись  мандатом.
Змінити це обіцяє тепер вже партія президента Зеленського.
Втім, пропонують одним пакетом голосувати за закони
про зняття недоторканності та імпічмент глави держави.
Депутати Верховної Ради нерідко прогулюють засідання
та часто голосують за відсутніх колег.
Двома руками.
За це й отримали прізвисько "піаністи".
Новий парламент обіцяє покласти цьому край.
Приміром, запровадивши кримінальне покарання за "кнопкодавство" -
від 51-ї до 85-ти тисяч гривень
та громадські роботи за прогули.
Вищий Антикорупційний суд офіційно запустили,
але щоб він не був перевантажений тисячами інших справ,
Рада має визначити, які саме провадження розглядатиме саме ця Феміда.
Судді мають зосередитися лише на корупційних злочинах
урядовців, які розслідує НАБУ.
Перед тим як піти в історію,
чинний парламент встиг підкласти українцям свиню.
За поданням депутатів майже усіх фракцій,
Конституційний суд скасував покарання за незаконне збагачення.
Справи щодо 65 високопосадовців закрили.
Серед завдань нових депутатів -
відновити покарання за незаконне збагачення.
Зняти мораторій на землю депутатам
вже не один рік і хочеться, і колеться.
Через нього в Україні - тіньовий ринок землі та корупція.
А власники паїв не можуть вільно їх продавати.
Нова Рада має скасувати мораторій
та ухвалити закон про обіг землі.
Втім, усе це лише наміри й обіцянки.
М’яч нині на боці Ради.